okay and then you look at them they're
to the best two-way players they play
both ends of the floor every night
challenging your best story inside we
didn't able to hit flush the foul
because they can choose the three-ball
the mid-range jumper and then play with
their back to the basket covington pops
it away towns finish for karl-anthony
towns so for the concussion on Wednesday
and he is out tonight so shorten the
guard Department this evening they
certainly have Leonard and George and
want to start for both of them Leonard
now with 11 in the quarter Lin terrific
got home great on the road doing an
excellent job because of the two players
nice cut from Wiggins left alone and
Napier found him
Wiggins step-back three is good
confident stroke from Wiggins to pay
attention in all the way a turd lays it
home send up the rookie Culver using the
Zubov screen Leonard methodical taking
taking hitting plus the foul will you
please give up and play the screener so
that they cannot turn the corner and get
that 10 to 12-foot jump shot George up
under and in timeout Minnesota you never
have to worry when you're cutting he's
going to get you the ball 17-point
clipper lead is ready in plays at ease
plus the foul and allowing a hundreds of
28 points a game during that stretch as
Paul George has topped the 40 spot 48 1
points tonight for Georgia season-high
they create the space and it just looks
like they're in the shooting drunk
it finishes and a chance for three for
karl-anthony towns it cannot make an
open shop and your key guys are getting
a shot rebound Minnesota they need a
bucket here yeah George's ups up with
himself you know that he didn't follow
through on the shot Wiggins what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content